the new york city fire department
lost 343.
the port authority police department
lost 37
and the new york city police department
lost 23.
and the word lost is not exactly correct
they were murdered by radical islamic
terrorists intentionally
murdered by radical islamic terrorists
the largest loss of life for the new
york city fire department
prior to that was 12 in a supermarket
collapse in brooklyn
the 37 port authority police officers
is the largest loss of life for law
enforcement in american law enforcement
history
in in one incident and the port
authority police is a small police
department so they
percentage-wise they lost more
of their force than the fire department
did
the new york city police department
number was 23
out of that 23 14 of them were their
elite
like for the fire department it's rescue
companies is the elite
for the police department it's nypd it's
the emergency service
unit and 14 of their guys
were murdered 14 of their guys
did the same thing the firemen did they
went up the stairs
knowing they likely were not coming back
these are the kind of heroes
who i want to talk about who i want to
point out
who fulfilled their oath when they
became police officers and firefighters
and that's why when you see a police
officer
or a firefighter in your community
or you see someone from the military who
is or has served
we all we owe all of them a debt of
gratitude
and their families because
the families are left you know without
kind of their leader right many of these
widows most of them were men from the
from police and fire department
most of the widows raised their children
by themselves like
mike lynch's widow denise who raised
that two-year-old and that six-month-old
boys by themselves you know by herself
and uh
god bless them for being able to do it
the
the effect of of these line of duty
deaths doesn't
stop in the first week or two it's for
the rest of these families
lives
michael's older son named michael lynch
jr
is now has now become
kind of i guess my nephew and i've been
helping
mentor him he's 22. yeah and uh
and he's doing some amazing things but
but that's because
his mom raised him very well
and he wants his dad
uh to be proud of him in his life and
what he does in his life
so he's going to join the military and
he's going to go fight for freedom
in america and there are thousands and
thousands of
the children of 9 11 who are doing
amazing things like this
my my best friend terry the captain the
tall captain right
who kissed me on the cheek um we found
out within a couple days that his wife
was pregnant with their first child
and that we were concerned that she
might not be able to hold the child
because she was 40.
we were worried about that we were
trying to find the bodies of our friends
we thought might still be alive we were
talking with the families about
do you want to have a memorial service
what about awake what about a funeral
do you want to wait do you want to do it
now how long do you want to wait
and then we had to make decisions about
how many memorial services and
funerals we to go to in one day i think
one day there was 25
you know and you had to make the choice
of
which of your friends you
want to say goodbye to and then try to
explain to the family
that you didn't go to well look i had to
go to this one i
you know and try and split our people up
um so that there were enough firemen
at this line of duty funeral
because usually we get thousands of
firemen in uniform and that now we could
get like 25
and we had to make sure that each
funeral each memorial service each wake
had the right amount of
firemen at it and
and then if you remember we had uh
the anthrax attack within a couple weeks
which
new york city was one of the targets of
and of course we thought it was all the
same terrorist attack
right coming at us and then in the first
week of november
we had the the crash of uh flight 587
in queens the plane came out of jfk and
went right in the ground
right and um and so we were trying to
deal with
all those things in addition to the
funerals and wakes and the families and
the
ins digging through the rubble at ground
zero
and uh i i don't know how we did it i
have no idea how he did it
i i don't know i don't know how i
survived it my brother and my friend
paul
would keep me away from the window or
keep me away from a door to a terrace
because they thought i was just going to
go out and jump off the building
and just be done with it and luckily i
was never that
you know i never had that instinct in me
in my life
um so
uh my younger brother had come down from
providence rhode island he was a fireman
up there
and uh he was trying to help me
in this very very difficult and
challenging time in my life
and by the fourth or fifth day i
couldn't even talk anymore
i lost my voice between
the dust and talking and yelling
i couldn't even i was trying so hard to
communicate
and my brother and another guy paul fire
chief from milwaukee
good friend of mine they like ripped me
off the chair and they're like
shut the [ __ ] up and follow us like
you're done you're
done and they kind of forced me out of
the room i was the guy in charge of the
room
and they were like no you're out you're
out i don't care you're out
only your brother and your best friend
could you know one of your best friends
could do that
and they took me across the street to a
makeshift
uh mash medical center
and they took me specifically into one
tent
and there was a young air force i call
him a doctor
i don't know if he's a doctor but he's a
really smart young guy
and they had already briefed him about
me
and that i would be combative and i lost
a lot of my friends
but they were scared that i was getting
very sick
and um he sat me down
and he said look tim you do whatever you
want
but i'm telling you
you are very sick right now you're on
the verge of going
into the emergency room being admitted
for pneumonia
you know your lungs are [ __ ] you're
everything
you're in trouble you you're in trouble
you're going to go in the murder you're
going to go in the hospital and be
admitted or
you can do what i tell you and i will
fix you
in 48 hours i was like that one sounds
better
he's like okay go home
shower shower shower shower takes
10 showers a day get this [ __ ] out of
your system
drink water until you explode
and take these pills and he said i
promise you in 48 hours
you will be 100 and you can come back
and work
and look for your friends but you have
to you have to do what i said
so i did what he said i went home um
in do you know what the pills were yeah
yeah they were um
i think i i always uh lose it but i'll
think of it in a second
um this the stuff they give you for
anthrax
the orange pills i'll think of the name
of it a minute but basically
it just cleans your body out of
everything everything good everything
bad
like you're on the toilet you're peeing
right you're like it just cleans your
system out
like nukes you it it does it nukes
everything out of your system
and then and then but then it allows
your
the good stuff to build back up and
protect you
and um and i and he was right and that
happened and i went back to work
uh uh 48 hours later and i
and i i don't know who this young air
force uh
uh corpsman or medic was but i think the
reason that i'm not sick
today um nearly 20 years later i've
never had cancer or anything
uh which is unusual most of the guys
have developed it
um is because this guy cleaned my system
out with
um with a drug early on what is the most
what is the most common
type of cancer disease that the first
responders that were there with you
developed
the most common was probably lung lung
cancer
probably um it's it's a common disease
in firefighters in general
but the 911 firefighters and police
officers
that was be the most common but
we they've discovered through all these
studies now 20 years later
that there are many very interesting
very different kinds of cancer that only
affect
us that are very specific to 9 11
responders
my friend mike who's the author of this
book and the brother of my best friend
patty brown captain patty brown
mike died of prostate cancer
just six weeks ago
he wasn't even firemen he came to find
his brother in the rubble
and and because of the week or two he
spent
down there 18 years later he developed
one week he spent one week yeah yeah
just one week
he developed this this prostate cancer
and it's
it's not a prostate cancer that
is known to the medical community it's a
different
prostate cancer that is much more
aggressive and
kills very quickly and that's what
happened to
mike mike was a medical doctor himself
um
and it killed him i'll say it killed him
within
18 months of him of them discovering it
and so i was out in las vegas holding
his hand when he
passed away about six weeks ago but this
is happening to us
on a large scale
police officers firefighters civilians
today i read about an fbi agent who
passed
i didn't know anything about it but he
passed in the last couple of days from
9 11 cancer he was an fbi agent down
there
it's it's killing us almost every day
now it's killing us
i